on est fait au mont saint antoine
c'est ici que vivent les aime de garçons
de la dpj
on va rencontrer quant aux jeunes
adultes les quatre ont passé une bonne
partie de leur adolescence par des
centres jeunesse
sauf que c'est important on voir un peu
comment ça se passe
un jeune qui essaient de salir type de
accepte de parler devant la caméra
les deux autres préfèrent rester
anonymes ils nous racontent leur passage
des centres jeunesse à la vie adulte
auprès des partis comme assez direct
puis le giron du complément libre
si c'est pour qu'on ferme la liberté
d'accès comme georges c'est comme
quitter sa famille on quitte les uns
donné ces enquêtes tout qu'on connaît
pour aller vers un autre monde les
quatre que soit un emploi fréquentent le
cégep ou l'université mais ils admettent
très honnêtement que de quitter les
centres jeunesse pour mener une vie
d'adulte n'a pas été facile j'ai que
côté social aux portes des changes est
pour nous tous un peu difficile parce
que quand on habite ici on est un peu
comme dans une coquille à protéger du
monde extérieur avec un environnement où
on dit chez les matériaux est ce que
chacun aura dimanche à 15 heures les 6
10 ans le narguer martin n'a pas
pilotage du crabe des neiges
mais jamais ils ne se sont sentis
abandonnés à l'âge de 18 ans quand est
venu le temps de quitter la dpj oui il y
en a maintenant 18 soir toujours en
sommes bien trop peu de nourriture de
vêtements stupidement oswald pas
l'argent pourtant htc y est de ce pied
il nous laisse jamais les mains vides
si le jeune il n'est pas réceptif à
l'aide des éducateurs
à ce moment là des cinq hommes
le sac à poubelle avec ses affaires
arrive première fois que j'ai réalisé
que j'avais plus de pauvres que j'avais
besoin d'aller voir un organisme protano
culture gelé peut faire parce que je
voulais pas prier sur mon nico tant que
j'ai mangé du riz pendant trois semaines
alive faut juste aller la chercher faut
être capable sérieusement je sais pas
pourquoi c'est comme ça ce qui les
dérange le plus c'est une image que les
gens des centres jeunesse et beaucoup de
monde qui pense que les jeunes qui sont
descendus depuis qu'ils sortent de glace
et jean type gentil je pense que c'était
nécessaire que je suis ici parce que
j'ai pourtant autonome sur plein côté
sujet cegep est ici ici vincent
maisonneuve race au canada montréal
[Musique]